[Music]
chips are magnificent creatures of the
sea built designed for the deep waters
of the ocean
but once you bring these magnificent
creatures to inland waters around the
world they get fairly clumpy the ship at
sea may travel 3,000 miles in a straight
line but the difficulty happens when you
get to port and that's when the ship
pilot takes over he's essentially like
that valet who parked your car the pilot
comes out usually on a small pilot boat
and then they climb up the side of the
ship on a small ladder up to the
wheelhouse to get the ship into the port
if it floats we are capable of moving it
[Music]
here at MPI we train ship pilots to
guide the largest moving objects on the
planet we have traditional classroom
training we have a state-of-the-art ship
simulator and then we have manned models
although these models may look like toy
boats they're actually precise tools
used to mimic the behavior of vessels if
you took a full-size vessel and shrunk
it down 25 times you can get very
reliable results a human being on our
models would be like an inch and 3/4
tall the man models there between 24,000
and 30,000 pounds of weight and they
have point four horsepower they've
behaved exactly like a show
this is real this is how it's done on
board all the ships around the world
starboard 10 degrees we surely would not
want to practice with a perfectly good
ship and see well captain we have to
drop bankers and simulate broke down
engines and steering so we do that with
these vessels it's a profession that I
think for me at the top of the maritime
field it's an awesome responsibility and
very challenging when I finished and
walk down the dock look back at the ship
and say yes that was a good challenge
[Music]
welcome to auction school what five
thousand what five and a womman five to
13 it sold by our number one due date
here we go rock'n'roll the Missouri
auction school was founded in 1905 it's
the oldest and largest auction school in
the world
the trains auctioneers in every aspect
of the auction profession and it's known
as the Harvard of auctioneering
introduced the item as 410 dropped to
five I'll give you the five and then go
to six so we start every morning at
auction school with group drills
just like an athlete would warm up we
need to warm up very good okay give
yourself a hand at auction school the
most important aspect is that auction
chant not 25 25 its soul the very
foundation of the auction profession I'm
a twenty dollar bid in now thirty nine
thirty when you gave me thirty I'm a
Tony down a bit okay let's try that the
auction chant is two numbers the money
that you have bid and the money that
you're asking for I have one dollar bid
now - now - will you give me - to
another bid now three now three when the
imagery
maybe give me 20 will you give me 20
feel that I said that's a good job and
as they sell more and more those filler
words will slur so it'll move a little
bit faster so I mean a little bit or not
one on one no button I do these
everything we give as everything gonna
Dominic things everything's ending we
give use they being important to I'm 41
here we given 4242 thanks sir
on a boat 108 per 100 on a polar sold
375 and that's what creates that nice
smooth rhythm-chan rubber baby buggy
bumper basic rhythm okay learning the
auction chant in a classroom setting is
important but you're not really an
auctioneer until you get to go to a real
auction and sell real items to real
person hours your way so if the student
auction you never know what's gonna come
up for sale and so you got to be ready
for anything first time in slot 75 you
got a stack of three turtles we've got
an old tablecloth jumper cables very
useful looks like you another stack of
turtles
lot number 66 three is a meat cleaver so
one of the most fascinating aspects of
the process is the transformation that
the students make throughout the program
so often when they first come to the
school they're hesitant they aren't sure
what they're doing a lot of them are
frightened even once they get up and
they sell and they realize yes I can do
this I can really do this you could hear
it in their voice I'm an auctioneer
great job that was really good
[Music]
one day I started on communication
rhetoric katana viniendo she wrote a
bikini kodanda Ramayya
oh here at Chaco the scooter ah Zhu et
named many
[Music]
choco school in Tokyo Japan
teaches people how to be mascots because
the business of being a mascot is big
really big mascots in Japan aren't just
for sports they're for police
departments towns malls Airlines even
prisons they're a staple of Japanese
culture in Osaka alone at one time there
was one mascot per 6000 residents to go
to me mo even not like Kodaka girl
anything like me for me there's a manga
Medina
no no death boom cannon not the money
today so she teaches them to wave to
dance not to pose and her class is
diverse he's a former chef she's the
housewife this guy he is a professional
mascot their ultimate goal it's to
perform but of course there are rules
number one no talking no character
though naka de esto no koi no yoga
chitta dough
yummy Omata krishna shimamu koi wa
that's an item number two don't show any
skin
he gave a salute dokuro miss a night
sorry wha
knock on door hi big night yes Nani me
cetera so they push on it not does your
mom know they miss a night
number three don't be rude these rules
are here for one reason a mascot is more
than just a costume
Oh Kira Meena yo doc a ded yo doc ADA a
hurry
Lata Donna Karan today's konnikova great
day 300 humans through calico so we do
particular know being a mascot is about
becoming something greater than yourself
you can escape into the character in
fact that's what you're supposed to do
you go to Mira
Papageno psychic okay today Ichi kataoka
Torito masa Widow kite a coup d'etat
songs IDs chocos been doing this for
over 30 years and her students well they
seem like they're on the right track
keep on practicing guys
[Music]
another season of America's pastime is
just around the corner the infield dirt
needs raking the batter's box needs
chalking at home plate needs to be hey
it was supposed to clean home plate that
would be one of the umpires
responsibilities got to make sure the
place clean look at all their excuse me
look at all the umpires thank you for 4
weeks every year 150 aspiring umpires to
send up to Ormond Beach Florida
well because of this guy introduce
yourself hunter sure my name is hunter
wendelstedt I'm a major league baseball
umpire number 21 and I am the
owner/operator of the wendelstedt on
fire school down here in Arman Beach
Florida
and students come from all over the
world
we've got Taiwan Dominican Republic
Puerto Rico Mexico Canada and Germany
represented internationally and I
believe we're coming from 36 of the 50
states but what do students learn a ton
Peyer school we're putting the
foundation down students learn the
difference between balls and strikes
foul bear guess there's no call for that
one safe and out but there's got to be
more to it right the most important
lesson of umpiring you always have to be
honest with yourself if an umpire makes
a mistake you need to man up and be
honest with yourself and you fix it so
it doesn't happen again
[Music]
[Applause]
so after countless calls and balls walks
and talks these Blues collect their
diplomas prepare to say goodbye to
umpire school ready to take their place
behind home plate at Yankee Stadium
right hunter best-case scenario seven to
nine years to get a full-time
major-league job you can go to med
school and law school in the same time
that it takes an umpire to reach it to
the major leagues okay so why would you
do it at all whether it's Little League
or Major League Baseball every umpire
has to sacrifice something for their
love of the game
maybe the majors won't come knocking any
time soon but thanks to the window set
on fire school these dumps are ready to
strike out at any opportunity I really
am back sure I get that metaphor hunter
that makes perfect sense
come on
[Music]
real boys please boys check one two
I used to feel like I have no talent I
used to feel like the only thing I knew
was the streets but now for like I can
rap my name is in Levy I am a school
counselor here at the new visions
charter high school for advanced math
and science - this is a space within my
counseling office where students come to
write and record tracks about different
emotional experiences that they've had
music is therapy
so he just created a space where kids
can come talk about their problems talk
about specific problems they have and
transfer all that energy into music
especially hip-hop music once you step
in the office is just a whole different
vibe you have other people who are
thinking as hard as you are about the
craft and like they can exchange other
concepts that you would have never
thought about and then you could also
apply your writing and record and make
something though
I represent the colors of youth I
colored the booth where every syllable
that comes out from under my tooth I
Thunderbirds prove to why I'm always
Rumble the truth the path to riches
always there I'm always in the pursuit I
love from Miss Olivia if you can put all
your thoughts and emotions and just one
song and you can you can try to rap with
it like just go ahead and do it I used
to be really shy I've learned how to be
more open with myself as a person I got
more comfortable I'm talking I'm making
friends and I'm speaking all that
through my rap I come into the classroom
and I automatically start rapping I
can't really express my feelings here
like I could act like myself I
definitely understand myself it's not
really about school I mean it is about
school because we're in school but like
it's about life and working towards
building something for yourself that you
love and enjoy and this is helping you
to understand who you are and how you
feel
[Music]
[Music]